[Musique]
ce mercredi 30 août Béatrice sigismo
vice-président du département accueilli
Dominique Garcia président de l'INRAP
l'Institut national de recherche
archéologique préventive sur le site des
fouilles actuellement mené au Musée
historique de Villèle
ment public national on fouille en
France près de 2000 sites archéologiques
en métropole et dans les outre-mer et
pour nous c'est important de voir chaque
chantier puisque ces chantiers de
fouilles sont des chantiers au service
des citoyens donc on répond à une
demande ici celle du conseil
départemental de la Réunion on analyse
le terrain on le documente l'archéologue
en fin de compte recherche des archives
et c'est de donner la parole aux
populations préoccupait le lieu et
ensuite on trace mail l'information donc
on ici on essaie en fin de compte de
rassembler une documentation qui va
permettre ensuite d'être exploité et
d'être utilisé dans le projet de
valorisation de ce site débuter en
octobre 2022 le chantier archéologique
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
transformation du domaine de la famille
Panon des bassins en lieu mémorielle
véritable musée de l'habitation et de
l'esclavage
à travers les fouilles archéologiques on
va découvrir vraiment l'histoire à
travers des fouilles dans le sol mais
aussi à travers une mise en visibilité
de ce qui est en surface et on va faire
bien sûr des découvertes et tout ça
s'est fait en plusieurs phases il y a eu
la première phrase phase où on a
vraiment fait des fouilles vers les
écuries les écuries se trouvent juste
devant nous ensuite on a fait une phase
ici sur les longères et il y a aussi la
phase sur les cuisines donc trois phases
maintenant on arrive à la quatrième
phase qui est l'usine proprement dit qui
est au centre et vous voyez on a
commencé donc le chantier sur l'usine et
donc ces quatre phases ont permis de
découvrir
des passages qui n'étaient pas visibles
en surface sur le bâtiment des longières
par exemple et ça nous donne une lecture
plus précise au niveau des sols on a vu
la nature des sols on a découvert le
cheminement entre
les écuries et le lieu où vivait les
esclaves donc ça donne vraiment une
belle lecture pour
les tout le scénario muséographique
qu'on va mettre en place sur ces lieux
avec la structure nouvelle qui sera au
centre filer les le plus grand chantier
archéologique des Outre-mer la
transformation du musée sera terminée en
[Musique]